while trying to manage my actual business.
At one point I joked that I had reluctantly pitched
each and every family member, friend, colleague, angel investor
and VC this side of the Mississippi.
Well, in the process of speaking to all these investors,
I noticed something interesting was happening.
I was getting asked a very different set of questions than my male cofounder.
I got asked just about everything that could go wrong with the venture
to induce investor losses,
while my male cofounder was asked about our venture's home run potential
to maximize investor gains,
essentially everything that could go right with the venture.
He got asked how many new customers we were going to bring on,
while I got asked how we were going to hang on to the ones we already had.
Well, as the CEO of the company, I found this to be rather odd.
In fact, I felt like I was taking crazy pills.
But I eventually rationalized it by thinking,
maybe this has to do with how I'm presenting myself,
or it's something simply unique to my start-up.
Well, years later I made the difficult decision to leave my start-up
so I could pursue a lifelong dream of getting my PhD.
It was at Columbia that I learned about a social psychological theory
originated by Professor Tory Higgins called "regulatory focus,"
which differentiates between two distinct motivational orientations
of promotion and prevention.
A promotion focus is concerned with gains
and emphasizes hopes, accomplishments and advancement needs,
while a prevention focus is concerned with losses
and emphasizes safety, responsibility and security needs.
Since the best-case scenario for a prevention focus
is to simply maintain the status quo,
this has us treading water just to stay afloat,
while a promotion focus instead has us swimming in the right direction.
It's just a matter of how far we can advance.
Well, I had my very own eureka moment when it dawned on me
that this concept of promotion
sounded a lot like the questions posed to my male cofounder,
while prevention resembled those questions asked of me.
As an entrepreneurship scholar,
I started digging into the research on start-up financing
and discovered there's an enormous gap
between the amount of funds that male and female founders raise.
Although women found 38 percent of US companies,
they only get two percent of the venture funding.
I got to thinking:
what if this funding gap is not due to any fundamental difference
in the businesses started by men and women?
What if women get less funding than men
due to a simple difference in the questions that they get asked?
After all, when it comes to venture funding,
entrepreneurs need to convince investors of their start-up's home run potential.
It's not enough to merely demonstrate
you're not going to lose your investors' money.
So it makes sense that women would be getting less funding than men
if they're engaging
in prevention as opposed to promotion-oriented dialogues.
Well, I got the chance to test this hypothesis
on companies with similar quality and funding needs across all years
at the funding competition known as TechCrunch Disrupt
Startup Battlefield has run in New York City
since its inception in 2010.
TechCrunch is widely regarded as the ideal place for start-ups to launch,
with participants including start-ups that have since become household names,
like Dropbox, Fitbit and Mint,
presenting to some of the world's most prominent VCs.
Well, despite the comparability of companies in my sample,
male-led start-ups went on to raise five times as much funding
as the female-led ones.
This made me especially curious to see what's driving this gender disparity.
Well, it took a while,
but I got my hands on all the videos of both the pitches and the Q and A sessions
from TechCrunch, and I had them transcribed.
I first analyzed the transcripts
by loading a dictionary of regulatory-focused terms
into the Linguistic Inquiry and Word Count software called LIWC.
This LIWC software generated the frequencies
of promotion and prevention words in the transcribed text.
As a second method,
I had each of the questions and answers manually coded
by the Tory Higgins Research Lab at Columbia.
Regardless of the topic at hand,
an intention can be framed in promotion or prevention.
Let's take that topic of customers I mentioned briefly earlier.
A promotion-coded question sounds like,
"How many new customers do you plan to acquire this year?"
while a prevention-coded one sounds like,
"How do you plan to retain your existing customers?"
During the same time,
I also gathered background information
on the start-ups and entrepreneurs that can affect their funding outcomes,
like the start-up's age, quality and funding needs
and the entrepreneur's past experience,
so I could use these data points as controls in my analysis.
Well, the very first thing that I found
is that there's no difference in the way entrepreneurs present their companies.
In other words, both male and female entrepreneurs
use similar degrees of promotion and prevention language
in their actual pitches.
So having ruled out this difference on the entrepreneur's side,
I then moved on to the investor's side,
analyzing the six minutes of Q&A sessions
that entrepreneurs engaged in with the VCs after pitching.
When examining the nearly 2,000 questions
and corresponding answers in these exchanges,
both of my methods showed significant support
for the fact that male entrepreneurs get asked promotion questions
and female entrepreneurs get asked prevention questions.
In fact, a whopping 67 percent of the questions posed
to male entrepreneurs were promotion-focused,
while 66 percent of those posed to female entrepreneurs were prevention-focused.
What's especially interesting
is that I expected female VCs
to behave similarly to male VCs.
Given its prevalence in the popular media and the venture-funding literature,
I expected the birds-of-a-feather theory of homophily to hold here,
meaning that male VCs would favor male entrepreneurs
with promotion questions
and female VCs would do the same for female entrepreneurs.
But instead, all VCs displayed the same implicit gender bias
manifested in the regulatory focus of the questions they posed
to male versus female candidates.
So female VCs asked male entrepreneurs promotion questions
and then turned around and asked female entrepreneurs prevention questions
just like the male VCs did.
So given the fact that both male and female VCs
are displaying this implicit gender bias,
what effect, if any, does this have on start-up funding outcomes?
My research shows it has a significant effect.
The regulatory focus of investor questions
not only predicted how well the start-ups would perform
at the TechCrunch Disrupt competitions
but also how much funding the start-ups went on to raise in the open market.
Those start-ups who were asked predominantly promotion questions
went on to raise seven times as much funding
as those asked prevention questions.
But I didn't stop there.
I then moved on to analyze entrepreneurs' responses to those questions,
and I found that entrepreneurs are apt to respond in kind
to the questions they get,
meaning a promotion question begets a promotion response
and a prevention question begets a prevention response.
Now, this might make intuitive sense to all of us here,
but it has some unfortunate consequences in this context of venture funding.
So what ends up happening
is that a male entrepreneur gets asked a promotion question,
granting him the luxury to reinforce his association
with the favorable domain of gains by responding in kind,
while a female entrepreneur gets asked a prevention question
and inadvertently aggravates her association
with the unfavorable domain of losses by doing so.
These responses then trigger venture capitalists' subsequent biased questions,
and the questions and answers collectively fuel a cycle of bias
that merely perpetuates the gender disparity.
Pretty depressing stuff, right?
Well, fortunately, there's a silver lining to my findings.
Those plucky entrepreneurs who managed to switch focus
by responding to prevention questions with promotion answers
went on to raise 14 times more funding
than those who responded to prevention questions
with prevention answers.
So what this means is that if you're asked a question
about defending your start-up's market share,
you'd be better served to frame your response
around the size and growth potential of the overall pie
as opposed to how you merely plan to protect your sliver of that pie.
So if I get asked this question,
I would say,
"We're playing in such a large and fast-growing market
that's bound to attract new entrants.
We plan to take increasing share in this market
by leveraging our start-up's unique assets."
I've thus subtly redirected this dialogue into the favorable domain of gains.
Now, these results are quite compelling among start-ups that launched at TechCrunch
but field data can merely tell us that there's a correlational relationship
between regulatory focus and funding.
So I sought to see whether this difference in regulatory focus
can actually cause funding outcomes
by running a controlled experiment
on both angel investors and ordinary people.
Simulating the TechCrunch Disrupt environment,
I had participants listen to four six-minute audio files
of 10 question-and-answer exchanges
that were manipulated for promotion and prevention language,
and then asked them to allocate a sum of funding
to each venture as they saw fit.
Well, my experimental results reinforced my findings from the field.
Those scenarios where entrepreneurs were asked promotion questions
received twice the funding allocations
of those where entrepreneurs were asked prevention questions.
What's especially promising
is the fact that those scenarios where entrepreneurs switched
as opposed to matched focus when they received prevention questions
received significantly more funding from both sets of participants.
So to my female entrepreneurs out there,
here are a couple simple things you could do.
The first is to recognize the question you're being asked.
Are you getting a prevention question?
If this is the case, answer the question at hand by all means,
but merely frame your response in promotion
in an effort to garner higher amounts of funding for your start-ups.
The unfortunate reality, though,
is that both men and women evaluating start-ups
display the same implicit gender bias in their questioning,
inadvertently favoring male entrepreneurs over female ones.
So to my investors out there,
I would offer that you have an opportunity here
to approach Q&A sessions more even-handedly,
not just so that you could do the right thing,
but so that you can improve the quality of your decision making.
By flashing the same light on every start-up's potential
for gains and losses,
you enable all deserving start-ups to shine
and you maximize returns in the process.
Today, I get to be that girl
walking by the pool,
sounding the alarm
that something is going on beneath the surface.
Together, we have the power to break this cycle
of implicit gender bias in start-up funding.
Let's give the most promising start-ups,
regardless of whether they're led by men or women,
a fighting chance to grow and thrive.
Thank you.
(Applause)